[MUSIC PLAYING]
The lecture processing
project is really
all about letting people
search inside videos.
Conventional search
engines are text-based,
so Google or Yahoo,
things like that.
You type in your text query,
and you find the documents
that you're interested in.
That's great, but with
video, you can't do that.
And we're living in an era
where there's more and more
videos are becoming available.
But it's hard to find
for little snippets
that you might be searching
for inside the video.
So we're using speech
recognition information
retrieval technologies to help
process the videos so that then
people can search them using
conventional text-based
mechanisms.
The way we process a lecture
is a series of steps.
First, we actually chop
it up into little 10
second increments.
And then we run a phonetic
recognizer over these chunks
to find out where the speech is.
Once the speech has
been recognized,
we put all the
pieces back together,
and then we can index it with a
conventional text-based search
engine.
My group starts processing these
materials once we have actually
speech transcribed into text.
And what we're doing is trying
to find structure in it.
Because if you have
textual material written,
you have sentences, and
paragraphs, and sections.
When you look at the
transcript, you don't even
have sentence boundaries.
So in order to be able to
support efficient retrieval,
you need to know what
is a proper unit.
So when a user asks about
a recursive function,
know which spot to show to him.
So our goal is to find the
structure in the text--
in the transcript.
So we have a publicly
available site.
And when you go there,
it has a video field.
But it also has a
conventional text field
where the user can type in the
keywords they're interested in,
or perhaps select a
subset of the courses they
want to search on.
So if they type in
the query terms,
they'll get a set of
hits showing the lectures
that somewhere in the lecture
the keywords that they
were looking for occurred.
And if they find something
they're interested in,
they can click on any
word at any point,
and it will start the video
up at that exact spot.
And below it, you'll see
a synchronized transcript
moving along with the video,
just showing the output
of the speech recognizer.
The left side of
that piece of plastic
is only positively charged.
So here it is.
The system so far had
around 2 million hits.
We were surprised to find
how much people like it,
and they really wanted
to have it expanded
in the full
interaction so they can
download their own lectures.
Right now we have a
pre-recorded set of lectures.
We just did access those.
And we got requests from
all parts of the country,
ranging from doctors
to legislators,
who were asking us
to use similar tools
for their own video libraries.
I think the technology has
two major applications.
One is for accessibility.
So for example, for
hearing impaired students,
video by itself is
not that useful.
So if you have text
to go along with it,
that would be very
useful for people.
Also very useful for non-native
speakers who might have
trouble following the speech.
There is another, I think,
interesting direction
is to try to sort of
solicit help from users
to improve the transcripts.
Because recognition
would never be perfect,
like in the next 10 years.
There always will
be some mistakes.
And it would be really cool
if the same way as Wikipedia
is created, when just users
are editing their materials,
if they can do the same
corrections for lectures.
And maybe add their notes,
and whatever information
they found useful.
So it is like sort of a source
which is evolving and improving
all the time.